الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الذي امرنا
فاعددت على القتال عن ارضنا ومقدساتنا
فاستجبنا وادخلنا عليهم الباب
فغلب وسدد رمينا وكبت
عدونا وجعلنا من حراس مصراه وسدن ارضه
المباركه وقدسه الشريف والصلاه والسلام
على نبينا المجاهد الشهيد
وعلى اله وصحبه ومن تبعه بجهاد الى يوم
الدين
وبعد يا ابناء شعبنا المجاهد الحر العظيم
يا امتنا الاسلاميه
والعربيه يا احرار العالم في كل مكان
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته 100 يوم على بدء معركه طوفان
الاقصى هذه المعركه التاريخيه
المفصليه في حاضر شعبنا
وامتنا هذه
الصرخه التي دوت في سمع الزمان وملات بقوه
الله بصر
الدنيا لتحرر كل الشعوب والامم
المستعبد ولتعطي نموذجا كيف للكف ان يناطح
المخرز وكيف لاحتلال عنصري نازي
بغيض يراد له ان يكون قدرا
لشعبنا ان يصبح الكيان الاكثر بشاعه امام
كل العالم تاره بسحق كبريائه والرد على عن
جيته في السابع من
اكتوبر
وتاره بمواجهه بطشه
واجرامه في معركه اسطوريه تبدو من نسج
الخيال ودرب
المستحيل نعود 100 يوم الى الوراء
لنذكر المتعامل والمتواطئين
والعاجزين من قوى العالم الذي تحكمه شريعه
الغاب نذكر بعدوان بلغ اقصى مداه على
مسرانا واقصانا
وبدا تقسيمه الزماني والمكاني
فعلا واحضرت البقرات الحمر تطبيقا لخرافه
دينيه مقيته مصممه للعدوان على مشاع امه
كامله في قلب عروبتها ومسرى نبيها ومعراجه
الى
السماء بل بلغت جريمه هذا العدو وحكومته
الفاشيه حد المطالبه بسحق شعب وتهجيره
وتدنيس مقدساته علنا وقتله ببطء في غزه
والضفه والقدس وفي فلسطين المحتله عام
48 وبات قاده العد دو بساديه وعنصريه
جبانه يتلذذون في تعذيب اسرانا وقتلهم في
السجون ويشددون الخناق على غزه في
سياق لارضاء
ناخبيهم واشباع غرائز جمهورهم المعبا
بالحقد
والكراهيه على كل ما هو فلسطيني وعربي
ومسلم فلم يكن امامنا سوى ان نفعل ما
امتلك ناه من قوه ونذكر العالم بان لهذه
الارض ولهذا المسرى رجال واهل
وحماه فكانت ملحمه السابع من اكتوبر التي
جاءت لتدع الثمن لهذا المحتل
وعصاباته التي ترتكب المجازر على مدار 100
عام ضد اهلنا وشعبنا وتحتل قبله المسلمين
الاولى وتسعى لاباده شعبنا وتصفيه وجوده
يا شعبنا المعطاء يا امتنا الكبيره 100
يوم ارتكب فيها العدو المجرم مذابح يندى
لها جبين
الانسانيه وان عداله الارض لو وجدت لحكمت
على هذا الكيان بنزع السلاح ولقد مت كل
قادته وجيشه للمحاكمه ولا اوقعت بهم اشد
العقوبه لكن العداله المختطفه في هذا
العالم حالت وتح دون ذلك مما يزيدنا قناعه
بصواب ووجوب ما فعلناه يوم السابع من
اكتوبر وما يفعله شعبنا ومقاومتنا منذ
عقود من مقارعه للاحتلال والاعتماد على
سواعد رجاله
ومقاوم واننا امام ما يمارسه المحتل
الجبان منذ 100 يوم فاجانا العدو من جديد
وكبد ولا زلنا نكبد خسائر فادحه واثمان
باهضه فاقت
وستفوز بفضل الله
وعونه نحو 1 اليه عسكريه
صهيونيه توغلت في قطاع غزه في شماله ووسطه
وجنوبه كما نفذنا مئات المهام العسكريه
الناجحه في كل نقاط توغل وعدوان الاحتلال
اعلنا عنها اولا باول وقد ابدع مجاهدو ولا
يزالون رغم الفارق الهائل في ميزان القوى
المادي والعسكري ورغم ما يرتكبه العدو من
جرائم اباده ومجازر هي علامه مسجله باسمه
في التاريخ الا ان مجاهدينا بعون الله
وتاييده حافظوا خلال 100 يوم على تماسك
صفوفهم وازدادوا قناعه بالدفاع عن ارضهم
امام عدو همجي بغيض فقدموا التضحيات
العظيمه وسطروا ملاحم عز نظيرها في هذا
الزمان وتمرس في عقدهم
القتاليه
واستبسل في تكبيد العدو خسائر هائله في
صفوف ضباطه
وجنوده وان الملاحم التي سطرها
مجاهدون مما اعلنا عنه وما لم نتمكن من
اعلانه بعد ستخلد كواحده من اعظم وابدع
واعدل واقدس المعارك في تاريخ
امتنا يا شعبنا العظيم يا صانع
المعجزات يا امتنا ويا احرار العالم ان جل
ما قاومنا ونقاوم به عدوان الصهاينه هو من
صنع كتائب القسام من عبوات ناسفه ومقذوفات
صاروا خ وراجمات
ومدافع ومضادات للدروع وقنابل مختلف
انواعها وبنادق القنص وحتى
الرصاص وهذه الصناعات لم تكن لتجدي نفعا
امام الترسانه الامريكيه الهائله
القذره التي نواجهها في ايدي مرتزقه
الصهاينه في الميدان لولا الصناعه الاهم
التي نمتلكها وهي صناعه الانسان المقاتل
ذلك الفلسطيني المقاوم
المجاهد الذي لا تقف قوه في الارض امام
ارادته واصراره على مواجهه قاتلي اجداده
وابائهم ومدني مسراه ومحتل تراب وطنه كما
ان اساءه وجه هذا العدو وكسر عدوانه لم
تكن لتحدث لولا عطاء وصمود وعظمه شعب حر
كريم شامخ يجود بكل عزه وكبرياء بكل شيء
ولا يعطي الدنيه في وطنه وارضه
ومقدساته فماذا ستفعل تكنولوجيا الصواريخ
والدبابات المحصنه والطائرات الحديثه
باسلحتهم قوه ايمان مجاهد يمكث شهرين
واكثر في عقدته الدفاعيه وموقعه
المتقدم منتظرا الظفر بعدوه وتنفيذ مهمته
محتسبا كل ذلك لله مؤمنا بعداله
قضيته وان شهادات مجاهدين الابطال
العائدين من خطوط المواجهه في شمال ووسط
وجنوب القطاع تؤكد مدى بطولتهم العظيمه
وايمانهم الكبير بمعركته واستبسال في
الدفاع والهجوم
والتصدي وهم في المقابل يعودون بشهادات
صادمه عن ضعف ايمان ودافعيه الجندي
الصهيوني
والمرتزقه اللمم وكيف يجرون الى القتال
جرا وكيف يبكون فزعا وجزع ويثرون امام
مجاهدينا رغم كل ما يحملونه من سلاح وعتاد
وغطاء ناري ضخم وان ما يعرضه جيش العدو
وما يعلن عنه من بطولات موهومه لجنوده هو
محل سخريه لاصغر طفل
فلسطيني
يا شعبنا يا اهلنا يا امتنا يا كل من
يسمعنا اننا في كتائب الشهيد عز الدين
القسام وبعد 100 يوم من المعركه والمواجهه
ومن التصدي للعدوان نؤكد على ما يلي
اولا ان معركه طوفان الاقصى هي معركه الكل
الوطني
الفلسطيني يقاتل فيها شعبنا بكل قواه
ومقاومين في خندق
واحد وان اي حديث سوى وقف العدوان عن
اهلنا ليس له قيمه في مسار هذه المعركه
التي ستتوسع يوما بعد يوم وتحرق هذا العدو
وكل من دعمه وسانده واعانه وان اهداف
العدو قد تكسرت على صخره صمود شعبنا
ومقاومتنا فها هي قياده العدو
المتغطرسه تتجرع الالم وتغوص في وحل الفشل
والاخفاق فلا التهج الذي يحلم به قاده
الحرب الارهابيون تحقق ولا التدمير
العشوائي حقق او سيحقق لهم سوى الخزي ولا
هم تمكنوا من استعاده
الاسرى كما سقط القناع عن هذا الكيان
النازي البغيض الذي ارتكب محرقه ضد
الابرياء
صنعت له عدوا ومقاتلا حاضرا ومستقبلا في
كل بيت فلسطيني وعربي ورسخت صوره الاحتلال
البشعه اصلا لدى كل حر في
العالم ثانيا انما يعلن عنه العدو من
انجازات مزعومه حول السيطره او تدمير ما
يسميه مستودعات اسلحه وما يطلق عليه منصات
صواريخ جاهزه للاطلاق وما يزعم انها انفاق
بالكيلومترات هي امور مثيره للسخريه
بالنسبه لنا وسياتي اليوم الذي نثبت فيه
كذ هذه الدعاوه وعبثيتها
ونود ان نقول بشكل
مختصر انه قبل السابع من اكتوبر وضمن خطه
العمليات لم يكن هناك اي مستودع اسلحه
للقسام في اي مكان في قطاع غزه ولا يوجد
لدينا منصات صواريخ مدخره كالتي يدعي
العدو انه دمرها ويعلن عنها كما لا يزال
لدينا الكثير لنقوله للعدو وللع في الوقت
المناسب اما فيما يتعلق بموضوع الاسرى
الصهاينه فنريد ان
نقول ان مصير العديد من اسرى
ومحتجزة في خطر داهم وكبير كل ساعه وقياده
العدو وجيشه يتحملان كامل المسؤوليه عن
هذا
الملف
ثالثا نحيي الايدي الضاربه الوفيه من
مقاتلي امتنا في لبنان العطاء والبطوله
وفي يمن الحكمه والايمان وفي العراق وفي
كل ساحات امتنا وننى الى امتنا شهدائهم
ونبارك جهد م
وعطائهم والعالم يرى كيف هرعت قوى الظلم
وشكلت
التحالفات واستدعت زبانيه النفاق والغطرسة
وضربات مباركه وقوفا في وجه المحرقه
النازيه الصهيونيه ضد شعبنا
واهلنا واننا اذ ابلغنا من جهات عده في
جبهات المقاومه بانهم سيوسع ضرباتهم للعدو
في قابل الايام في ظل استمرار العدوان على
غزه فاننا لن نكل ولن نمل في دعوه كل
احرار الامه ان يهبوا لنصره اقصام ومسرى
نبيهم الذي يس سير الصهاينه المجرمون في
خطوات عمليه لهدمه واقامه هيكلهم وهو ما
اخرنا بدمائنا في غزه منذ 100
يوم ولاجله كانت ملحمه السابع من اكتوبر
وعلى كافه مجاهدي شعبنا العظيم ابناء
العرور والعياشي وطوال في ضفتنا المباركه
وكافه مقاتل الامه الذين بقيت دماء عربيه
ومسلمه تسري في عروقهم ان التقطوا هذه
اللحظه التاريخيه ليقولوا كلمتهم للعالم
ويوقعوا انضمامهم لطوفان الاقصى واعلموا
ان كابوس الزوال الذي يعيشه العدو يهرول
اليه قادته النازيون بارجلهم نحو قدر الله
المحتوم بدحر
وتدبيرهم
رابعا نرى ان من واجبنا الجهادي والديني
ان نحيط ملياري مسلم في العالم
بان العدو الصهيوني وخلال 100 يوم دمر
معظم مساجد قطاع غزه ودنس واحرق وجرف تلك
التي وصلت اليها الياته على الارض واوقف
الاذان والصلاه في حرب دينيه واضحه
استكمالا لما بداته عصابات الصهيونيه
الدينيه من حرب على المسجد الاقصى وهذا هو
نذير شؤم ودمار على هؤلاء القتله النازيين
اذ لا قبل لهم بالحرب على الله وهذا ثابت
بنص التوراه والانجيل والقران لكنها دعوه
ايضا لكل مسلم على وجه الارض ان يعي طبيعه
الصراع
وخلفياته وطبيعه هذه الحكومه الصهيونيه
المجرمه سليله عصابات الهاجانا الارهابيه
وان اضعف الايمان لمن عجز عن نصره الدماء
البريئه ان ينصر دين الله اذ هدم صوامع
وبيع وصلوات ومساجد يذكر فيها اسم الله
كثيرا فلتقم صلوات القيام والقنوت في هذا
الشهر الحرام في كل مساجد العالم ولترفع
الدعوات لرب العالمين بنصر عباده المؤمنين
ودحر وتدمير المجرمين المعتدين ولينصرن
الله من ينصره ان الله لقوي عزيز ختاما يا
شعبنا العظيم الصابر المرابط 100 يوم ما
كلت عزائم مجاهدينا وما لالت لهم قناه وما
وهنوا لما اصابهم في سبيل الله وما ضعفوا
وما
استكانوا 100 يوم وشعبنا العظيم الاسطوره
يقف شامخا على ارضه رغم الالم والجراح
ويسطر اروع ملحمه في الصمود والتحدي
والكبرياء ويرابط على ساحل من سواحل
الشام متمترس على ثغر عسقلان متمثلا بشرى
نبينا صلى الله عليه وسلم
مستظل باجل الحه ملائك الرحمن
وطوبى لكم يا اهل غزه وطوبى لك يا ارض غزه
يا خيره الله من ارضه ساق اليها خيرته من
عباده فترقبوا نصر الله القريب ووعده
بالفتح الكبير ودخول المسجد الاقصى
المبارك يقينا بالله وثقه به وان فجر
الحريه لكل شعبنا يقترب بامر الله ولن
يضيع الله جهاد ودماء الام اهلنا وشعبنا
والله غالب على امره ولكن اكثر الناس لا
يعلمون وانه لجهاد نصر او استشهاد والسلام
عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته